there's been an escalation in the
conflict between azerbaijan and armenia
azerbaijan's president ilam aliev says
that his troops are now in control of
sushi
which is one of the most important
cities in the fight given its strategic
position
overseeing the regional capital of
nagorno-karabakh
we have correspondents on both sides of
the story at a moment we'll get reaction
from armenia
hara abdul hamid is in yaravan for us
but first let's speak to osama bin javid
who's in
baku what did the president of
azerbaijan have to say
[Music]
well adrian this was the wartime speech
of a president who's changed his twitter
profile
to him in the khakis of his military
saying
that the strategic town of shusha has
been taken uh
by his military this is a city which is
called shusha
on the other by johnny side and shish
shushi
on the armenian side it is a
strategically important town
uh both historically as well uh as
for the memories of the people who've
been displaced from the nagorno-karabakh
region
ali of saying that it is a historic
moment for their country
and it has been made possible uh because
of the unity of the nation
as well as a complete confidence in
their armed forces
saying that he has fulfilled the dream
of his father and he has
advanced the technology and the
capability of his military so now that
when the time was right uh they've been
able to liberate the strategic town it
is important
because it separates the uh strategic
supplies coming in from the for the
armenian side
to the city of stepanaka also
because there is a lot of hopes and
aspirations that the people here in
azerbaijan had tied to the city of
shusha
it was much anticipated and now right
after this uh uh announcement you can
hear behind us
uh cars who've been which have been
going around for the last couple of
hours people out with their flags
and saying uh we've been speaking to
people in the street and they think
that this is the time and it is an
indication that not just shusha
but all of the areas in the conflict
conflicted areas in nagorno-karabakh
will be taken by the azerbaijani army
and it will be a matter of months
before they take over the whole
territory al jazeera is osama bin javid
reporting live there
uh from baku let's go to yerevan then
al jazeera's abdul hamid is there so
harder azerbaijan's president says his
troops are now in control of sushi
yadavan says oh no they're not
well iran actually didn't say anything
at all uh
at this stage uh it's been quite
actually quite the silence has been
quite deafening
we have heard from the president of the
self-declared republic
of nagorno-karabakh he did not deny
that the azeri forces were in sushi as
they call it here
shusha as they call it in azerbaijan but
he did say that there was still
intense fighting ongoing at this stage
uh but this is big make no mistake this
is a huge
uh blow uh for the armenian side
uh back in the 90s it took it was i took
actually a battle that lasted quite a
few months for them to be able
to take uh that town this is a very
symbolic
uh town in armenian history anyone would
tell you here this is extremely
important for them
and also because it's about 10
kilometers away
from the capital stepanakert which the
azeri's called
han kandi now from what we understand uh
the azeri forces would be about
four kilometers away uh from sepana
occurred certainly
on social media uh we have seen um
uh videos of hundreds of cars
fleeing that area some going down those
hills
uh coming down from sushi and others
coming uh out of the karabakh region
into armenia so it's certainly a very
difficult moment for the armenian side
hara abdul hamid reporting live there
from yaravan
many thanks hoda